l'école nationale supérieure
d'aéronautique a été créée en 1948 elle
est installé dans des bâtiments qui ont
été ceux d'un couvent en créant ainsi un
symbole au coeur du poitiers
d'aujourd'hui le respect d'un passé
historique et l'ouverture dynamique vers
un grand avenir
lens m'a accueille des promotions de 60
élèves ingénieurs recrutés par concours
en france et à l'étranger dans les
classes préparatoires aux grandes écoles
des études durent trois ans et sont
couronnées par un diplôme d'ingénieur
qui sanctionne un haut niveau de culture
scientifique et technique mon but ce
serait d'être ingénieur dans la branche
automobile nice matin ah bon mais alors
comment se fait-il que de l'automobile
vous passiez par par le biais de c'est à
dire qu'il n'existe pas d'école
d'ingénieur spécialisé dans l'automobile
on est obligé de passer par l'air aux
techniques par la pièce si vous la
mécanique m'intéresse
la halle à l'aéro technique aussi sur
tous leurs recrutements sur
l'astronautique est comme
l'astronautique est une marge de
l'astronomie c'est surtout l'astronomie
qui m'intéresse
voilà comment se fait-il que vous êtes
dans ce texte il est ingénieur horticole
spéciaux n'est pas un peu curieux en
tout cas inhabituel non inhabituel
peut-être mais curieux ça ne l'est pas
c'est la voie que j'ai choisie
et qu'est-ce que vous le voudrez
essentiellement faire de la recherche
aérospatiale
mais si je ne peux pas je ne vois aucun
inconvénient à rentrer dans l'industrie
comme ingénieur je peux enfin j'ai mieux
enfants
magnifique
dans l'industrie aéronautique
la valeur du diplôme délivré à l'issue
des trois années d'études à lens m'a est
incontestable qui ne se pose d'ailleurs
aucun problème de placement industrie
moderne celle du présent comme celle de
l'avenir l'automobile l'aviation
l'industrie atomique
la technique spatiale absorbe facilement
ces jeunes ingénieurs
on peut dire sans se tromper que de
nombreuses grandes réalisations qui ont
fait ou font le renom de notre pays dans
le monde sont issues des études
poursuivies allant sma c'est le cas de
certains éléments du paquebot france de
concorde
pour en arriver là des élèves ingénieurs
suivent naturellement des cours mais
aussi sont confrontés avec le concret
tels que projet devant la planche à
dessin ou la machine à calculer travaux
pratiques sur machines outils sur
appareils électroniques et laboratoires
de l'école auquel s'ajoute le centre
d'études aérothermique de billard sont
remarquablement équipés
un stage prolonger dans les laboratoires
de recherche de lancement permet
d'ailleurs aux futurs ingénieurs de se
familiariser en dernière année avec les
techniques d'expérimentation les plus
modernes
des études qui sont effectuées au
laboratoire de thermique de lancement
dans sur le plan de l'enseignement que
sur le plan de la recherche concerne
deux thèmes essentiels
il y à l'étude des transferts de chaleur
et d'étude des phénomènes qui sont liées
à la thermodynamique
aux températures à chacun de ces deux
thèmes est affecté à laboratoire vous
êtes ici dans le laboratoire de
transfert de chaleur vous pouvez y voir
des étudiants qui sont en bas de
manipuler sur des problèmes de
convection et des chercheurs
le travail sur des problèmes modernes de
transfert de chaque au laboratoire de
thermodynamique des hautes températures
on étudie essentiellement
problème des détonations l'étude de
l'état des gaz ligure détonation est la
pièce maîtresse est la plus
spectaculaire de ce laboratoire est sans
conteste le générateur de placement
ainsi lens madone aux étudiants en plus
d'une solide formation universitaire
traditionnelle une orientation
scientifique et technique dirigé vers
les options de l'avenir qui leur
permettront de rentrer directement dans
l'industrie bel et grand service de
recherche de la nation mais vivant à
l'école et avec l'école le futur
ingénieur trouve sur place de nombreuses
activités intellectuelles ou visites
bibliothèque salle de jeux ou de
réunions sont à la disposition de tous
on peut pratiquer à l'école dans des
installations modernes
pratiquement tous les sports du tennis
au rugby en passant par le handball le
volley ball l'athlétisme l'haltérophilie
les agréent ou le judo
ainsi après trois années bien remplies
les ingénieurs de lens m'a peuvent
porter à travers le monde
la réputation de l'université de
poitiers